le sommes mais bon gorbatchev en bonne
voie nous aux accords aujourd'hui sur le
désarmement
politique lina l'union ont entonné aux
états généraux de l'opposition à paris
les meilleurs joueurs mondiaux
s'affrontent à paris le jeu d'échecs à
la recherche et de la médiatisation
bonsoir et puis le premier test
démocratique pour la roumanie demain 16
millions d'électeurs vont élire leur
président mais aussi leurs députés et
leurs sénateurs à la veille des
premières élections libres depuis 1946
le 19/20 vous propose une page spéciale
réalisée par les envoyés spéciaux de
l'a3 et par norbert balit que nous
rejoignons tout de suite en direct avec
arrêt merci eric retour à bucarest sous
la pluie depuis pratiquement quatre
heures de l'après midi retour à bucarest
donc sur la place de la révolution là où
ont commencé les premières
manifestations devant le siège du comité
central du parti communiste roumain pour
nous accompagner au cours de cette
édition spéciale
un invité un invité romain roumat que
vous connaissez bien
c'est le fameux homme à la barbe blanche
jay louvre icahn vice premiers ministres
de roumanie
il nous rejoindra dans quelques instants
vous l'avez dit en première partie du
19/20 eric demain 16 millions
d'électeurs roumains se rendront aux
urnes pour élire leurs représentants à
l'assemblée
leurs représentants au sénat et élire
leur président dans les différentes
éditions de la 3 nous vous avons déjà
présenté les portraits des trois
principaux candidats à l'élection
présidentielle
comme je vous le préciser il y à une
demi heure environ nous avons choisi non
pas de vous présenter la roumanie de
bucarest
mais de vous présenter la roumanie
profonde la roumanie des régions comment
vit-on ici ces élections dès que l'on
sort de la capitale roumaine
c'est ce que nous avons cherché à
découvrir avec toutes les équipes de la
croix présente ici à bucarest
à quelques kilomètres dans le sud de la
capitale roumaine vit la famille de yann
marié il a deux enfants
et comme vous allez le constater il
arrive également ici que la politique
divise les générations pascal verneau
philippe guinet regarder dans la
banlieue de bucarest un jardin ouvrier à
proximité de la voie ferrée
yann 56 ans et cheminots il cultive le
jardin que lui attribuer les chemins de
fer en famille yann était paysan
sa fille aînée dit avec malice qu'il a
quitté la terre car il y avait trop de
travail
la seconde fille il y en a 23 ans se
prépare aux métiers d'ingénieurs réveil
à 6 heures tous les matins retour à la
maison à 21h il y en a et dessinatrice
dans un bureau industrielle le matin
étudiante la famille elle passe près de
trois heures par jour dans les
transports
à écouter les autres passagers évoquer
le scrutin dans sa tête
la politique est loin la course à
l'argent aussi que je fais un métier que
j'aime c'est un travail de création
nous ne sommes pas bien payés
contrairement à certains mais si nous
pensons uniquement l'argent nous allons
devenir des machines et robots qui ne
vivent que pour ça
yann le père est un dissident dans l'âme
il y a quelques années ils voulaient
rendre sa carte du parti
la peur du chômage et les conseils de sa
femme blanc n'ont dissuadé
aujourd'hui comme beaucoup de roumains
l'évolution de la situation le rend
perplexe tchane réalise at
tout ce que j'ai obtenu c'est en
travaillant honnêtement ce fut difficile
car j'ai gagné je peux rester graver des
coupes pas trop compris à votre
contribution
c'est une partie seulement du front de
salut national qui a fait la révolution
celle ci est l'oeuvre des jeunes gtoi
les ouvriers c'est vrai qu'il ya encore
un communiste au pouvoir et chassé tout
d'un coup ce jour là sur la place de
l'université pour la première fois il y
en a la jeune fille bien sage rendait
visite aux manifestants son père qui
votera pour ion iliescu lui a donné son
autorisation dans la vallée de la joue à
350 km au nord de bucarest vivent ce que
l'on appelle les privilégiés du régime
ils sont mineurs sous nicolas ceausescu
leur révolte avait été réprimée dans le
sang
aujourd'hui ils sont considérés comme
les bras séculier du pouvoir qui sont
ils comment vit-il pascal verre d'eau
philippe guinet les mineurs de la vallée
de l'alzou dur à cuire et fer de lance
du front de salut national
les voici midi après six heures de
labeur l'équipe de nuit fait surface
comme tous les ouvriers lorsque nous
revoyons la lumière dit stéphane nous
nous disons encore une journée difficile
derrière nous
pourtant depuis la révolution les
mineurs font figure de privilégiés 33 %
d'augmentation des salaires
un jour de congé supplémentaire par
semaine la retraite à 45 ans au lieu de
50 sous ceausescu les avantages sociaux
qui ne compense pas la peine d homme le
travail pénible le risque de grisou
omniprésent les lenteurs du progrès
technique
la mine n'est mécanisé que par endroits
ailleurs c'est la même situation qu'il
ya 24 ans lorsque j'ai débuté
des pelles des pioches des machines a
perforé le risque de grisou nous y
pensons tout le temps mais nous
consacrons beaucoup de temps à notre
sécurité
stéphane comme beaucoup de ses camarades
est un ancien paysan mais la solidarité
du gros l'appartenance à une noblesse
ouvrière avec ses gestes singulier série
constitue pour lui une véritable fierté
le pays dit il a besoin de nous pour
extraire son charbon plus de 50% des
ressources romaine proviennent de cette
vallée de la loue autres solidarité pour
ces mineurs qui ont souffert sous la
dictature celle des ouvriers qui se
reconnaissent dans les idéaux du front
mais les sardes 12,6 abouti comme marc
chamard si on les appelle les mineurs
qui sont déjà venus à bucarest eux
reviendront mais seulement si l'ordre
est troublée ils sont de la discipline
et du calme pour travailler
une menace qui s'adresse bien sûr aux
manifestants de bucarest
sympa les mineurs mais fidèles à leur
réputation
voilà trois cents kilomètres mais cette
fois ci à l'ouest de bucarest
on trouve le village du bas nestea tout
près de tir rue morin
voilà nous avons un problème nous avons
ouï oui tout à fait nous avons un
problème de liaison avec bucarest et
norbert balit était en train de vous
parler de ces élections telle qu'elle
était ressentie dans les villages et de
vous parler de la transylvanie et de
prendre pour exemple le petit village du
bas nestea au coeur de la roumanie
profonde où c'est le sentiment anti
hongrois qui domine toujours
reportage à nouveau de pascal verre
d'eau et de philippe guide nous sommes
les maîtres de la transylvanie
ce chant patriotique romain qui est
aussi l'hymne de battre à une
association culturelle hyper
nationaliste est interprété tous les
jours par les écoliers libanais stif il
y a deux mois
armés de leurs bâtons les hommes du
village se sont rendus à tyr go moore
est ce le chef lieu de la région pour se
battre avec les hongrois ici le
contentieux est ancien brimades
vexations de la part de l'administration
hongroise pendant la guerre et flambée
de violences depuis la chute de
ceausescu
ils veulent être les plus puissants
et aujourd'hui comment ça se passe avec
eux chaque manquerait des situations
comme assez rare dans l'aude à lourdes
ils veulent la transylvanie maintenant
ce n'est pas possible
aujourd'hui la situation est calme
iban et stevie comme en 1950 à des
années lumières de la révolution
roumaine
la campagne électorale est inexistante
les thèses du front et la popularité de
yoni et les secousses impose à tous les
villageois pour sergei qui est aussi
l'instituteur du village et possède
quelques animaux destinés à la
consommation familiale
c'est d'abord le pain qui compte
aujourd'hui on trouve du sucre de la
viande de porc du chocolat et produits
de luxe du café après des années de
pénurie le débat politique actuel le
chagrine la période actuelle est triste
profondément triste tout cette
atmosphère néfaste de lutte pour le
pouvoir entre les différents partis rite
orthodoxe pour l'enterrement d'un des
anciens du village tous les hommes et
les femmes diva nestea cet après-midi
ont abandonné leurs occupations
la mort d'un proche c'est un événement
les élections ne sont qu'une péripétie
la liaison sont je crois rétabli
maintenant avec bucarest envers val it
vous m'entendez oui eric retour dans
cadre du cac reste avec toutes nos
excuses pour cet incident technique
si vous avez pris 7,1 cette édition en
cours je vous rappelle que vous êtes sur
l'a3 comme d'assister à une édition
spéciale du 19/20 sur la place de la
révolution
en compagnie d'un invité je vous le
disais il ya quelques minutes
genova icahn l'homme à la barbe blanche
comme on l'appelle en france qui est
vice premier ministre roumain
mais voilà jean reuilles cannes vous
allez quitter le pouvoir
gâteau parce que vous serez probablement
sénateurs pourquoi est-ce que vous allez
quitter le pouvoir
vous serez invisible mais voyons ça
c'était seulement une façon de parler
parce que
ne quitte pas le pouvoir c'est le
pouvoir exécutif et comme sénateur je
vais appartenir pouvoir législatif n'a
pas le pouvoir qui vous quittent
monsieur est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que le fond de salut
national est aussi discrédité qu'on le
dit ou est-ce que constant non ce n'est
pas surtout qu'une question de image
artificielle qu'on veut à des raisons
électorales imposé par la voie des mass
media mais vous avez réussi en six mois
a dit la fille d un bon capital de
sympathie chez vous à l'étranger
également l'échec répète le que vous qui
le dites mais en tout cas front de salut
national a changé la face de la roumanie
dans les premières deux semaines est ce
que vous êtes fatigués du pouvoir ce que
faisait beaucoup appris du pouvoir vous
sembliez puise ainsi sophie je suis
peut-être fatigué physiquement comme ça
parce que on a beaucoup travaillé
monsieur recon en se promenant dans
bucarest en discutant avec les roumaines
et les roumains on a l'impression qu'il
ya une certaine défiance qu'il ya une
certaine suspicion ajouté sur sur ces
élections
oui
c'est peut-être un effet de certains
événements compte surtout en bucarest
mais qui n'ont pas eu qu'une influence
locale est mineure les élections vont se
dérouler sous le signe de la loi
électorale qui a été voté oui parce
qu'il ya certains partis d'opposition
comme le parti national paysans ou parti
libéral qui remettent un petit peu en
cause de la régularité de ces élections
malgré la présence des observateurs des
observateurs sur lesquels nous
reviendrons dans l'est sur dix est ce un
observateur et tout va se dérouler
normalement et dans des conditions
absolument légale que j'observais qu'il
en a parlé reste un nouveau problème
nouveau problème de liaison sont avec
bucarest nous retrouverons norbert balit
en direct dans soir 3 à 22h30 avec un
dossier complet portant sur la roumanie
et son avenir maintenant la roumanie
face à son avenir après les élections
libres qui se dérouleront donc demain à
bucarest et dans l'ensemble de la
romaine dans l'actualité aujourd'hui à
l'étranger les principales questions de
fond pratiquement résolu pour un
véritable accord sur le désarmement
entre américains et soviétiques
conversation marathon à moscou
commentaires de pierre babey accord sur
l'interdiction des armes chimiques
accord sur les négociations start james
baker n'aura pas perdu son temps à
moscou il aura même peut-être sauvé le
prochain sommet bouche gorbatchev de
washington résultat soviétiques et
américains vont vraiment diviser par
deux leur fantastique arsenal nucléaire
mais 50% de douze mille têtes il en
restera tout de même six mille
principaux points d'achoppement résolu
donc aujourd'hui les missiles
balistiques mobile à têtes multiples les
américains n'en disposent pas alors que
les soviétiques de leur côté possède et
modernisent leur ai 16 24 autre
divergence surmonter aujourd'hui les
missiles de croisière lens et d'avion
divergences sur la portée à prendre en
compte 1000 km propose des américains
forts de leur supériorité dans ce
domaine six ans contre eux proposent les
soviétiques
sur la lancée des déblocages de moscou
il y aura donc bien avant la fin de
l'année signature d'un accord start sur
la limitation des armements stratégiques
américains et soviétiques font
maintenant assaut de bonne volonté ils
envisagent d'ores et déjà la mise en
chantier d'une nouvelle réduction
baptisé prosaïquement start 2 en france
manifestation silencieuse cet après-midi
à paris pour demander je cite un
référendum sur le rétablissement de la
peine de mort pour les assassins
d'enfants manifestation à laquelle
participaient plusieurs parents
d'enfants assassinés reportage de
nathalie darrigrand est dénommée poupart
elle s'accroche au portrait de céline
céline jourdan sa petite fille retrouvée
assassinée violée en juillet 88 près de
son village en haute provence elle sa
mère est venue avec sa famille
manifester cet après midi à paris
aérienne sera très long moment alors
réclamant une visite
donc aujourd'hui je suis là pour les
autres enfants qui risquent d'avoir le
même sort qu'à lui ces liens et corey
potter ça s'arrête deux ans après le
drame l'instruction de l'affairé céline
jourdan n'est pas fini injustice laxisme
lourdeur de la machine judiciaire
répondent les parents il faut une
solution
la leur le rétablissement de la peine de
mort pour précise-t-il les assassins
d'enfants
commente simplement c'est que dans ce
pays on a eu le courage de prendre les
français pour des adultes et qui
répondent aux mêmes à ce problème
cet après-midi ils étaient plus de 300 a
demandé à référendum sur le
rétablissement de la peine de mort
une délégation a été reçue au ministère
de la justice ainsi qu'à l'élysée hier
six parents dont les enfants ont été
assassinés ont fait savoir qu'ils
n'étaient pas solidaires de cette
revendication
à paris toujours après plusieurs
discussions avec les forces de l'ordre
les anciens combattants d'afrique du
nord ont pu déposer en fin d'après midi
une gerbe devant la statue de georges
clemenceau le front uni les associations
d'anciens combattants d'afrique du nord
avait organisé une manifestation pour
obtenir notamment des pouvoirs publics
la fille du sud de la carte de
combattant pour tous et le droit à la
retraite à 55 ans pour les demandeurs
d'emploi politique
l'appel à l'union c'est
incontestablement le maître mot des
états généraux de l'opposition qui se
sont déroulées à paris mais la volonté
de créer une confédération rpr udf n'est
pas tout à fait sans arrière-pensée
aussi bien chez jacques chirac que chez
valéry giscard d'estaing
eric piermont quel est le plus unitaire
des deux depuis deux jours jacques
chirac et valéry giscard d'estaing
rivalisent de déclarations en faveur de
l'union de l'opposition jacques chirac
proposé hier de réunir le rpr et udf
dans une grande confédération ce matin
valérie giscard d'estaing lui a répondu
chiche samp et essence
bac en adaptation de confédération de
l'opposition becton impôts mais les
rations sûr qu'on peut enfin de bonnes
volontés cache mal les divergences qui
existent en réalité entre les deux
hommes qui n'ont même pas réussi à se
rencontrer pendant les deux jours hier
giscard est arrivé au beau milieu du
discours de chirac aujourd'hui chirac
lui a rendu la politesse mais plus grave
il ya aujourd'hui de réelles divergences
de stratégie
chirac veut accélérer la désignation
d'un candidat commun de l'opposition en
organisant des primaires à la française
giscard semble avoir complètement oublié
ce projet
chirac a choisi de combattre le front
national et les idées qu'il véhicule
alors que giscard lui a toujours ménagé
jusqu'à présent une ambiguïté
bienveillante à l'égard de jean marie le
pen
sans doute pour ne pas se priver des
voix du front national en cas de besoin
valéry giscard d'estaing qui doit
prononcer demain un discours attendu
après les événements de carpentras aura
l'occasion s'ils le souhaitent de lever
cette ambiguïté et autres faits
marquants la qualité sous forme de
télégrammes avec le commentaire ce soir
d'hervé dit anatoli soloviev et
alexandre balle andine les cosmonautes
soviétiques actuellement en mission à
bord de la station orbitale mir sont
bloqués dans l'espace
le véhicule soyouz qui devait les
ramener sur terre est tombé en panne la
situation n'inquiète pas outre mesure
les deux hommes qui vont prochainement
entreprendre une sortie pour réparer le
soyouz un vaisseau automatique leur a
déjà livré il ya une dizaine de jours le
matériel de dépannage ils n'attendent
plus pour commencer les travaux qu'une
échelle spécial acheminés par un autre
vaisseau qui décollera le 1er juin
les trafiquants de drogue ne savent plus
quoi inventer pour échapper à la police
cette fois des contrebandiers ont
carrément creuser un tunnel sous la
frontière américano mexicaine pour
passer de la cocaïne creusé à 9 mètres
de profondeur ce passage qui mesurait
une centaine de mètres de long relier un
entrepôt de douglas en californie à la
propriété d'un riche homme d'affaires
mexique
des agents fédéraux qui ont découvert ce
tunnel estime que sa construction qui a
duré plusieurs mois a coûté 10 millions
de francs
les pousses de charles bronson actrice
gennari nand est mort d'un cancer du
sein à l'âge de 54 ans gît la glande qui
avait été à plusieurs reprises la
partenaire de son mari à l'écran était
très apprécié du public américain qui
suivait attentivement son combat contre
la maladie
un combat qu'elle avait décrit dans un
livre devenu un best seller cinéma2
vedette aujourd'hui au festival de
cannes gérard depardieu noyé par la
foule sur la croisette
et puis le metteur en scène david lynch
qui est venu au bras de la comédienne
isabelle la rossellini présenter son
dernier film sailor et lula film qui a
reçu un accueil assez froid de la
critique mais très enthousiastes de la
plupart des fans du réalisateur entre
autres d' elephant man comme pour godard
ou pour cyrano
j'ai envie de dire que la présence ou
l'absence de sailor et lula au palmarès
sera sans doute l'un des thèmes de
polémique quand le jury rendra son
verdict lundi soir en sport fignon
deuxième de l'étape du tour d'italie cet
après-midi limoges pratiquement assuré
du titre de champion de france de basket
le sport en bref avec le commentaire de
rémy nous dit chez nous
antibes ko d'entrée cet après midi à
limoges devant le tandem collins groupe
c l'équipe de dakoury toujours maîtresse
du jeu
battus de 15 points cents à 96 les
antibois devront gagner la seconde
manche de cette finale du championnat de
france samedi sur la côte d'azur
s'ils veulent disputer une belle face
aux limougeauds
mais quelle mouche a donc piqué le
défenseur valenciennois pelletier pour
qu'ils offrent à strasbourg réduit à dix
le but égalisateur contre son camp à
trois minutes du coup de sifflet final
mon truc donne finalement la victoire
aux alsaciens pendant les prolongations
valenciennes pleurs et strasbourg
connaîtra ce soir son adversaire pour
les barrages et l'accession en première
division sont concernés en priorité
nice et le rp un giovanni fidanza
apporte à l'italie sa deuxième victoire
en deux jours dans le giro intéressant
pour la suite
le sprint de fignon parti tout seul à
300 mètres de l'arrivée et qui termine
2e de l'étape
au classement général l'italien bougnot
conserve son maillot rose et la joie du
vainqueur de l'étape fondriest le
tournoi d'échecs le plus original le
plus prestigieux est peut-être le plus
spectaculaire du monde se déroule ce
week-end à paris les meilleurs joueurs
kasparov pas ce qui est le jeune prodige
français joël lautier s'affrontent dans
un tournoi doté de 500 mille francs de
primes pour le vainqueur les échecs à la
recherche d'un nouveau public est en
quête d'une plus grande médiatisation
reportage de jean philippe djian et de
christian de carnelle terminée l'époque
où les pousseurs de bois se retrouvaient
dans des arrière salles de café
maintenant les échecs sont médiatisés à
l'extrême présentateur officiel circuit
vidéo il écran géant
chaque geste chaque option tactique est
disséquée par des spécialistes que les
spectateurs peuvent écouter à l'aide
d'un casque individuel finies aussi les
parties interminables
ici les champions s'affrontent en deux
fois 25 minutes la moindre erreur
d'inattention est catastrophique
ça va être extrêmement ça vraiment est
allé très vite ce sont ceux dont on n'a
pas l'habitude des échecs on pense que
vont d'habitude ça dure pas mal de temps
c'est à dire 3 4 heures c'était un parti
de la savait vraiment extrêmement rapide
et il faut être très entraînés j'ai dit
que je voulais être champion du monde en
93 il ya un match de championnat qui va
se dérouler la bientôt à la fin de cette
année entre karpov et kasparov donc à ce
corps n'est pas sûr d'être encore là en
quarts de finale joël frôlé
l'élimination
l'ancien champion du monde boris spassky
tu réussis à le déstabiliser
et ce n'est qu'après deux blitt les
prolongation de cinq minutes que joël se
qualifie pour les demi finales
plus jeune grand maître international le
français espère rencontrer le numéro un
mondial garry kasparov en finale
un face à face inédit que joël lautier
prépare depuis longtemps ce tournoi
d'échecs de paris vous pourrez le suivre
en direct demain après midi à 15 heures
dans l'émission sport 3 dimanche
l'émission de michel rey qui vous
proposera également du volley ball en
direct la revanche de la rencontre
france brésil les français ont été
battus hier soir par les brésiliens 3
sets à 0
les rapports du tiercé quarté qui s'est
discutée aujourd'hui à saint cloud il
fallait jouer le 4 le 8 et le 9 pour
gagner dans l'ordre 2522 francs 5
entrées dans le désordre vous le voyez
504 francs 50 le quarté + vous ajoutez
le 7 14 1800 francs 80 et dans un ordre
différent 1117 francs 20 nora l'instant
la météo complète de fabienne amiach ne
manquez pas ce soir à 20h30
la première partie de thé ou évinçant le
film inédit de robert altman consacré à
la vie de vincent van gogh je vous
retrouverai à 22h30 pour soir croit dans
lequel nous développerons deux pages
spéciales l'une consacrée à la roumanie
l'autre au festival de cannes a tout à
leur très bon début de soirée
le mignon
et
ouais